i find myself holding my breath just
because i'm so
stressed or just so anxious about this
whole thing
this year i'm voting for biden and
harris because the number one thing
on my agenda is to get trump out the
white house this year i'm voting for
president trump because he's the most
pro-life candidate that we have on the
ballot i'm waiting for bonnie because i
want to see change for disabled black
immigrant indigenous lgbtq plus and
trans wives there's no such thing as a
labor party or a working class party in
the united states and so i
most often register as a democrat
because you have to work within the
system
but i'm also not foolish i'm a
conservative and i'm going to be voting
for president trump this year you
shouldn't be voting for somebody just
because you don't respect or like
the other candidate they are running
against i really wanted to find out why
everybody hated trump so much
i never really found out this year we're
faced with the prospect of either having
a democratic
republic where everybody gets a voice
in government and has their civil rights
protected
or having flat out fascism i hear a lot
of people pointing fingers at trump he's
a fascist
okay tell me why he's a fascist please
do the research and inform yourself
so you can actually elaborate on these
opinions that you might have this year's
election is very important to me because
i believe the left is trying to expand
the powers of the government
through democratic socialism as a
conservative i believe we need to have
limited government
i don't want to believe that i live in a
country where the leader is openly
racist and self-serving
in 2020 because i mean america it's like
been there done that i got the t-shirt
not only am i worried about my and other
disabled people's rights in terms
of education employment health care and
housing
but i'm also worried for our immigrant
communities and families
2016 i voted for trump and i'm glad i
get to vote for him again
because he has done an excellent job of
the last four years after
three and a half years nearly four years
of con
after con and and theft after theft
if you're still on the con well
once again i i don't know how to tell
you this but you're just plum simple
i hope that the people who voted for
trump in 2016
come out to the polls in 2020
and make a better decision than they did
last election
so it is currently election day i have
voted i got up bright and early at 6 30
a.m to go vote
no significant news has come out as of
right now i
haven't slept much last night as usual
down here in orlando florida we're still
in the thick of an election
florida's been the thick of uh crooked
elections ever since hector were a pup
uh it goes uh well all the way back to
1876 when the florida electors were in
disarray
it threw the election into the house of
representatives and they didn't even
bother to settle it there what happened
was a back room deal between
rutherford b hayes and samuel which left
our african-american brothers and
sisters at the mercy
of jim crow laws and the clan
and repression and basically they were
disenfranchised
until the civil rights act of 1960. we
might not have a winner today
because of so many mail-in ballots and
i think that there's a lot of people
voting today it's been predicted that
more trump supporters were going to come
out on election day to cast their
ballots
just because we don't trust the uh male
imbalance system
thankfully the pulling location isn't
too far for me so i could literally
drive to it
who knows how accessible it is gonna be
so i guess we're just gonna have to find
out and literally last week we had
hurricane zeta hit us really bad too
things were missing that i literally
forgot about the elections until
yesterday i mean yesterday the power
went out a couple of times because
they're still fixing the electricity
poles so i would imagine that
accessibility
and getting to those polls is probably
one of the largest issues right now in
louisiana
there's going to be a lot of breathing
exercises going on in this house
[Laughter]
i remember i entered briefly once for
disability rights louisiana
and one of the biggest main issues in
voting for them was
accessibility getting to the polls is
very hard for people in new orleans and
again the countryside is just as bad
i can't imagine the voting turn out
if it was accessible to everyone
it's currently 6 49 pm eastern standard
time
on election night i'm feeling good
things are looking good so far
trump has a lead in new hampshire
indiana and biden is leading kentucky
they haven't called florida yet but it's
not looking good i think it'll go to
trump
i planned originally to sit in front of
my tv and by my nails until it was all
over but that was driving me
insane and i don't know if you can tell
my voice i'm very anxious i'm very
trying to harness my emotions so it's
currently 7
15 p.m eastern standard time things are
continuing to improve for president
trump
he is winning uh eight to three in terms
of electoral votes
uh biden blew his lead in kentucky trump
has won kentucky
i've been waiting for the polls to come
in so far trump is trending
in a lot of good states man we had a lot
of victories in states like you know
mississippi
uh louisiana they went on to call
florida eventually
we'll see i'm super excited about it
though when
indiana turned red today the day of the
election
i can almost understand how people who
don't vote
or people who are not fans of voting
can feel like my little vote didn't make
a difference
but i think that it's really important
to watch
tonight's coverage and to see these
electoral college votes and get an
understanding of how
the system works and know that we don't
live in a country that's just majority
vote so
obviously i'm disappointed in indiana
for turning red
but it's a group project and i gotta
count on everybody else to pull through
the only states that i'm particularly
worried about right now is pennsylvania
ohio and texas
tell me something good joe we feel good
about where we are
do you because i'm a little iffy it is
too early to make a solid determination
at this point we'll have to wait
uh until you know a later day we don't
know when that day is going to be
it could be a week from now we don't
know
voter suppression remains a winning
strategy for the gop
i believe we can come together if
everyone agrees that these won the best
candidates then how about we just you
know provide better candidates next time
do our best to go out and make sure that
we vouch for people
that we truly believe represents the
ethos of america right i'm still friends
with everybody he's still going to come
over brisket i don't care
if we didn't win this time we'd
definitely win next time we'll just go
harder
that's all i gotta say whatever the
result is we're still gonna organize and
we're still gonna fight for our
communities
we're still gonna take care of each
[Music]
other
[Music]
foreign